what's up everyone carlos here this
video is being made under the assumption
that you've all seen the latest marvel
movie black widow
i feel like we've given you a lot of
time to do so but if you haven't yet
save this video for later go watch the
movie then come on back because this is
your spoiler warning
and this is e.t canada's nerdler there's
this thing that you do when you whip
your hair when you're fighting
with the arm and the hair and you do
like a fighting pose
it's a yeah it's a fighting pose you're
a total poser
all that time that i spent posing i was
trying to actually do something good
to make up for all the pain and
suffering that we caused
trying to be more than just a trained
killer black widow finally sheds light
on natasha romanov's backstory showing
us the infamous budapest incident
and introducing us to characters that
shaped her into the widow we know it is
as action-packed and quick-filled as any
marvel outing but when it's all said and
done
one big question remains for me
what's next for natasha
amazing friends because we know what's
next for natasha
she's dead this movie sets up that
yelena melena alexie and antonia are
determined to free the rest of the
widows around the globe
but is there an on-screen mcu future for
these characters
let's discuss
wow sorry
i'm allergic to the midwest okay let's
start with the ending shall we the
post-credits scene reveals that new fan
favorite yelana you're a total poser
bolova
not only has a very cute dog named fanny
but she also works for the mysterious
contessa valentina allegra de la
fontaine
still fun to say i want to raise oh yeah
you and me both
believe me you're going to earn it
i've got your next target i thought i'd
hand deliver it
maybe you'd like a shot at the man
responsible
for your sister's death this clearly
sets up that elena will play a big role
in the upcoming hawkeye series with
clint barton and kate bishop likely
running from fighting and maybe
eventually teaming up with this black
widow
also given fan reaction to florence pew
in this role it's probably safe to
assume she'll be around for a while
her connection to val makes her a
shoe-in for this thunderbolts or maybe
dark avengers team that's in the works
that said if she becomes a hero by the
end of hawkeye i could see her as a
founding member of a new
or maybe mighty avengers team so
yeah she's probably sticking around
are any booby traps around here or
anything we need to know about i didn't
raise my girls to fall in traps you
didn't raise us at all
molina on the other hand her mcu future
isn't quite as clear
as the mom of the family we could
suppose that in her quest to free all
the widows worldwide
she becomes a guardian figure for them
as well could she become the leader of a
group of assassins composed of newly
liberated widows molina in the mcu
differs pretty greatly from who she is
in the comics
where she's a villain and enemy of black
widow named iron maiden
and that army she's part of they're
called the femizans
so yeah i don't know if we'll ever see
her again but if we do marvel can you
just make sure her group isn't called
the famazons
thanks i grab hold of his shield
and face to face it's a test
of strength
[Music]
[Laughter]
between his old war stories and fabulous
singing voice alexis shostakov aka the
red guardian makes quite an impression
in black widow
so much so that fans are pretty eager to
see him suit up again if only to see if
he could
indeed go toe-to-toe with captain
america
are those old war stories true this is
what actor david harbor told me
about the matter i mean that's a funny
idea i think to a certain degree and i
don't say this with derision
i think to a certain degree he is
psychotic so
what he believes happened
and whether or not it happened in
reality in his mind it very much
happened i mean i think that he
he lives in a world of his own
so it really was unimportant in terms of
playing him whether or not they happened
for
me they have i mean for him the reality
is the reality so i just went with that
it would be interesting if there were
flies on the wall in those situations
because there is even
prison at one point somebody calls him
out on a certain technical thing in the
story
so i yeah i don't know how much of it is
real how much of it is fabricated but
for me playing the character all of it
was very very real and very important
so maybe it didn't happen in the past
but could it happen in the future
kevin feige recently said he'd like to
see red guardian go up against sam
wilson's captain america
which pretty much cements alexi's return
but how could it happen
the movie itself gives us some
intriguing clues
what year was this i don't know
like 8384 captain america was still
frozen in ice then
why are you calling me a liar huh see
that big guy alex's arm wrestling with
there
that's officially ursa major who in the
comics
is a teammate of the red guardians in
the winter guard russia's very own super
team
merchant major is also an actual mutant
bear so yeah there's your potential
first mutant in the mcu surprise
there have been several different red
guardians in the comics but with both
alexi and ursa in this scene
i choose to believe that the winter
guard is a team mostly in the mcu
sometime
in the near future i mean we all want
david harper back in that red suit and
the introduction of a team of russian
superheroes
inspired by the avengers would be a
great vehicle for it
say hello
now the big shocker in this movie came
in the form of revealing that taskmaster
a near unstoppable killing machine that
can mimic the fighting style of any
opponent
was actually a mind-controlled antonia
dracov the girl who natasha thought she
killed
on that fateful day in budapest the end
of black widow sees these two battling
it out with natasha eventually freeing
antonia
and antonia finding a family among the
other recently liberated black widows
say what you will about the reveal some
people liked it some people hated it but
it did what a good reveal should
it surprised people and got them talking
which according to star older kirilenko
was kind of the point it's fun to be a
secret it's fun
to have to reveal it to surprise people
it's
uh i think you know i love to be
surprised
so i so it's it's good to do it to
to the others um and so yeah the
character is so cool i'm just i'm just
thrilled to be part of it
antonia may be free of her villainous
father's mind control but her ability to
copy the fighting skills of others
remains
making her a formidable opponent to
pretty much any fighter in the mcu which
makes the potential match-ups
pretty exciting it should be noted as
well that in the comics
taskmaster's real name is anthony you
know
anthony antonia
i just don't anyway whether this plot
twist works for you or not i don't think
anyone wants this to be the last
appearance of taskmaster whether it
continues to be antonia
or the mantle's handed down to some
other tony down the line
so what do you think which of these
characters would you like to see make a
mighty marvel return
if you got any ideas of how you see it
happening share it in the comments below
and if you'd like to see more nerdy
stuff from us
please hit that like button thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
you